new at 11 o'clock students across Clark  County staging a walkout this week  bringing awareness to climate change  students at five area high schools are  set to participate in a peaceful protest  on Friday those schools include Clark  Palo Verde and Coronado among others  they plan to walk out at different times  students say the effects of global  warming is a big concern here in Nevada  especially due to our hot and dry  climate  we thought it was really important that  Las Vegas had a chapter because Las  Vegas is the fastest warming City in the  nation here at Clark we're going to be  gathering students to walk out in front  of the Clark High School sign and we're  going to have an emcee chance rallies  and it's going to be peaceful  the School Board of Trustees have been  made aware of the walkout that is again  happening on Friday as another  demonstration will be held at six  o'clock Friday night just outside of the  federal courthouse